uh it being 9 30. uh as uh chair of
division three of the house finance
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared
by the governor as a result of the covet
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note that there is no physical
location
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting
which was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i'm confirming that we're
providing
access to this meeting to the public by
telephone
and also through the zoom link
the committee is using a zoom video
webinar for a remote meeting
all members of the committee and the
staff estate agencies with
agenda items have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during the
meeting through the platform
the public has access to
contemporaneously watch and or listen to
the meeting on
zoom or phone following the directions
and links provided in the house calendar
starting at house calendar eight
running all the way through i think the
current version is house calendar 16.
those are all hanging on the
gen court public website
uh we have i can assure you we've
provided public notice of the necessary
information
by accessing the meeting we previously
gave notice to the public
of the necessary information for
accessing the meeting telephonically
those instructions are also in the house
calendar
now we are providing a mechanism to the
public to alert
us if there are problems with access and
you do that by emailing
lba underscore f-i-s-c-a-l
at l-e-g dot state dot nh dot
u s um and then if we find out that
the public is having trouble accessing
the meeting
we will adjourn and reschedule please
note that all votes that we take during
this meeting shall be done by
roll call vote and i don't anticipate
doing any roll call votes at least until
all seven of the committee are present
so representative bean let's start the
meeting by taking a roll
call attendance and then each member as
they state their presence
announces their presence please also let
us know if there's anyone in the room
during the meeting
so that we can apply with comply with
the right to know law
representative bean will you take
attendance please
yes sir mr chair uh representative
representative walner is here i'm in
concord
in my home and my husband is not in the
house
representative nordgren representative
norgren here in hanover in my dining
room slash
office representative rogers
catherine rogers i'm in concord in my
apartment with my dog romeo
representative uh present home alone in
my home office
representative edwards i'm in
my home office in auburn i have family
in the house
but uh my door's shut i don't expect
i'm representative bean i'm at home in
guilford my house my wife
is here she's in the other room uh
representative weiler i think is uh as
larry all others are
president accounted for representative
wyler i'm sure is attending the
joint legislative fiscal committee or
one of the
related committees associated with it um
okay so uh i'm gonna go over
today's agenda i emailed it to the
committee members
an image of it probably 40 minutes or so
ago
but for the members of the public we
have a very
very full day and we've got
some guests coming in at scheduled time
so
so we may have to take some uh recesses
and take some diversions around things
but um this is uh
as far as the plan goes this is the last
major day where the division three
is gathering information and uh
discussing
uh some of these things before some big
votes on hp1 and hp2
next week so um
so we have a tight agenda we're going to
start by talking about
hb 2 section 34.
then we have mr wetters and
um i think goulet dennis goulet the
commissioner of doit
is going to join him uh at around 10 30
and we'll discuss uh hb2 some more
sections 35 37 41 24 and 25.
somewhere in here we're going to break
for lunch and when we come back from
lunch
uh we'll uh we'll ask the lba to
update us on the status of all the hb2
work to include the work we've done
through the morning
and to include some
some new draft hb2 so that people have
situational awareness on what we're
doing
make sure that ms rounds before she
leaves at 2 p.m has an opportunity to
talk to us about
six or seven footnotes that are in hb1
uh we have an update on the department's
um considering
to work with us on using enhanced fmap
for a couple of other areas of the
medicaid budget
representative wallner i think you're
expecting that
we can come back and talk to you one
last time on a on a vote for the uh
tanf child care flex is that right
yes throughout the day we're going to be
talking about h w
hb one and uh some with proposals and
votes and
[Music]
last but not least and it's so important
we'll
probably break in when we have a ways
and means
up update i i want to wait for
representative weiler
as a minimum before we do that but
i am cautiously optimistic that we have
good news breaking um so stay tuned
okay with that uh
mr ripple would you pull
up hb2 and share it
and take us to section 34.
and what i'm going to do is because this
is a
topic that i assume there's a lot of
public
interest in i want to i want to set us
up for this discussion
just a little bit differently than we
normally do
but i i want to provide
transparency and an opportunity for
okay so section 34
is what we're going to talk about as
proposed
as introduced it's there on lines 4
5 6 7 and 8.
as i understand these five lines these
were in last year's hb2 identical to
this can you confirm that mr ripple
is that that is identical language to
last
last years or last terms um
hb2 item isn't it it's close but not
quite exact there was some additional
language in the beginning that said
except for funds appropriated in the
operating budget
other than that the language is
identical
okay so um i know that
representative erica leone
l-a-y-o-n i'm still not sure exactly how
to pronounce her name
wants to introduce an amendment to this
section 34.
so would can we call that up do you have
a
uh amendment what is it
uh zero eight three zero hotel that you
can go up
it's up on the screen now roll it to
where people
can read the entire thing okay through
line 20.
okay so um so for the purpose of
bounding the scope on what we're doing
here today
we are considering replacing
section 34 with this language and i want
to
wait 60 seconds so that everybody can
read section 34. i think this has been
posted on the lba
website which is uh which has made it
publicly available but i
i want to make sure that we're all
everyone who's participating today has
and then representative bean you're
you're gonna be my uh
guinea pig raise your hand when you
you've had a chance to read the whole
thing
please
and you can you can bring representative
erica leon
i'm not sure she could hear your
representative
representative nordgren your hand is up
she took the hand down um so
representative bean you raised your hand
so good
we're through okay um
so uh representative leon do you want to
uh speak to your uh amendment
is she in uh yes thank you mr chair
yes i'm here can you hear me yes you're
great
fantastic thank you mr chair and thank
you honorable members of the house
finance committee
for the record i'm representative erica
leon from rockingham sixth dairy
i'm introducing amendment 2021-08308 to
section 34
of house bill 2. section 34 of house
bill 2
discusses family planning programs and
uses the language from previous budgets
it is actually the in the bill it's
actually the exact same language as the
house bill for the budget
administrative rule h ew 509.07
states that the services which shall not
be covered as family planning or family
planning related services
and abortions are called out
specifically as a non-covered service
despite solid work from previous
previous legislative bodies family
planning funds remain more fluid than
intended
and recipients are making the most
efficient use of those funds that are
available and they're working right up
to the extent of the law
this language here is to tighten up the
language so that no really means no
a reproductive health care facility is
defined in the statutes and by using
this definition combined with the
current
rules and regulations this this simply
sets out into law what is already in the
administrative rules and has already
been included in previous budgets
this amendment just clarifies the intent
of the original section 34
it prevents confusion of funds and it
honors the state rules and policies so i
ask that you adopt this amendment
are you willing to take questions um i'm
willing to take a few i have a heart
stop at 10.
okay it's um is uh i
i think you were going to invite mr mike
um let me pull up his
mike tyranny i'm so wrong yes yeah so uh
mr ripple would
please bring in mr tierney as well
good morning good morning uh mr tierney
uh thank you for joining us
as i'm bringing you over with uh
representative leon because i understand
uh
you worked with her and with a group of
legislators and that
and that you're an attorney that helped
draft this so i i thought i would
ask you to introduce yourself and and
ask if you'd be willing to take
questions as they're presented
uh by the committee and maybe the
participants
absolutely thank you sir would you
introduce yourself
for the record yes michael tierney
i'm here on behalf of cornerstone and as
you indicated i have
had some discussions with representative
leon about
this particular amendment and how this
particular moment has been
upheld in previous court cases including
russell sullivan
all right well thank you for that uh and
notice that representative nordgren and
representative rogers have their hands
up
we'll go in that order representative
norton
yes um i just wanted to clear up any
confusion
are are we open for public discussion of
other people who were on this
there will be an opportunity for uh
people who are calling in
to um to to make a short statement
um so um
so do you have another question well i
just wanted you maybe to repeat
how people do that because i it was my
understanding late last night
that there was not going to be an
opportunity for testimony so i just need
to have it clarified for the public
thank you i've never said that so i
don't know where that came from
uh it's always been my intent to make
this
publicly accessible and transparent
conversation so
i'm sorry that some somebody interjected
some confusion into this
yes yes i have a question for um
representative leon um the state budget
as you said
already prevents any family planning
dollars from going towards abortion
um and it's been a long-standing part of
the
budget and part of the practice and we
all know that federal dollars cannot go
towards that
if this amendment passes it risks
patient access to affordable birth
control
std testing and cancer screenings
and a number of
people that get their health care of
women especially who get their health
care
in the western part of the state would
be
unable to get any of that health care
a number of clinics that are providing
that as i said the std testing is almost
exclusively i believe 95 97 of the std
testing
in fact is done by clinics that
also provide abortion services so you
close them down because it's physically
impossible for them to
do as you require in this i know in 2017
in fact
there was a senate bill that was
defeated which was this exact same
language
so it's being recycled now so um
what is your exact intent of this is
your intent to in fact
close down these clinics
um thank you representative rogers for
your question
i am a financial analyst and an
economist and i
see how much how finances can flow from
one section to another
my intention is not to shut down these
clinics my intention
is for state funds to be used for the
intended purpose which is family
planning services
there has been an issue with with these
funds going to pay for overhead and
other issues which
benefits the provision of abortion
services which would otherwise
need to be be paid for by those
non-state funds
right now there are fun state funds that
are going to support
political advocacy and other issues and
this is something where we need to have
a clear line
and we need to make sure that we are
supporting these important family
if there's an issue with some places in
the western part of the state
that that's i guess that's something
that can actually probably be better
referred to by some of the
some of the other experts that are here
but this is an issue where i've seen
companies that that move these funds
around and we need to make sure that
it's clear because our state doesn't
allow that funding and if you're funding
everything
up and around an abortion then that is
not a clear use of funds and we're just
trying to clear clear up those
definitions and make sure that
no means no and these state funds are
appropriately allocated
i could have a follow-up mr
representative edwards yes ma'am
um are you aware that the passage of
this amendment
is going to be defunding um multiple
safety net providers for people
especially low-income peoples in around
the state
that in fact according to the department
in um fiscal year 192 or
2020 97 of the chlamydia and gonorrhea
testing in the program
was completed by the providers that
you'll be closing down
89 of the pap tests and 67 percent of
breast exams
were completed by these same providers
if this amended past
amendment passes we're going to be
defunding safety net providers
during a pandemic where would you have
these patients go
or do you just not care about the low
income care
preventative care low income cost
care for preventative folks because
you'll be leaving them
um thank you representative rogers are
you saying that these funds need to be
provided to abortion providers so that
women can get basic health services
are you saying we need to fund that i'm
saying that these are the providers that
do this
they also do provide abortions a very
small part of what they provide
but the way your amendment is worded
which is the exact same thing that was
in the federal
um law that provided was in there for
the last few years
and which was the same thing as a senate
bill that was defeated
in 2017 is in fact
going to affect the people that provide
same health care to low-income women in
parts of our state
and i gave you the statistics of the
amount of health care they provide
so in effect with what you thank you
thank you
we do the thing that we have the
statistics for
and we have evidence that they do will
be stopped
for wait wait wait wait so so
um representative rogers uh let's try to
treat this like a
a typical public hearing if you have a
question to ask representative leon and
then
representative leon would you please uh
wait until
uh uh representative rogers completes
your question
i'm trying simply to say that i've given
her the evidence the department has
given us
of what these providers do do she's
making claims without any evidence
of what she thinks they do and let's
that's a that's too strong uh
representative rogers you don't know
what her evidence
is you're you're asking her for evidence
uh which is a fair question
but you should not assume uh
whether she has evidence or not until
you faster
well do you have evidence of your claims
and
if you do would you provide it to us and
are you aware you'll be shutting down
providers that in fact do what the
thank you representative rogers attorney
tyranny has some of that evidence i
am not a lawyer i am an economist and a
financial analyst
i know that when i was younger i chose
to receive my services at some of these
providers so that i could make sure that
my funding was going towards
what i believe to be important services
this is a choice that other women with
health insurance can choose to do
this does not necessarily defund them it
just makes this more of a choice
issue i would like to defer to that
evidence to rep
to um to mr tyranny because i i worked
more on this language and this
clarification of use of funds
mr tierney are you prepared to answer
representative rogers question regarding
evidence
yes thank you um so this uh
amendment does not defund anyone um this
amendment
just requires that any entity
that is providing abortions
and also wishes to receive state funds
for other purposes such as a family
planning project
needs to be physically and financially
separate
from an abortion providing reproductive
health facility
the abortion providing reproductive
health facility as defined in the
statute
is just a very limited number of places
and those places need to be physically
and financially
separate from an entity um
other location that could provide other
services
the five locations that i'm aware of um
that are defined by the statute are all
within two miles of
another medical clinic or of a
hospital that does also provide a
full set of services without providing
abortions so in manchester and concord
in keene there are all alternate medical
providers
who are not reproductive
health facilities as defined the
statutes otherwise known as abortion
clinics
do you have a follow-up yes you ask for
that to be separate which is again
something that is
nearly impossible for places but you
also in this amendment
talk about a state-funded process shall
not encourage
promote or advocate as a method that it
prohibits
them from assisting women obtaining so
basically if any woman asks if they know
where they can obtain an abortion
if they inquire so if they even mention
the word
they lose the funding i think that this
is impossible to do
if somebody asks you and you just deny
them information
that that can't be done so it's an
impossible amendment
and you know that this is going to cost
them any kind of funding that they get
right now representative rogers yes i do
if you'd let me finish
i don't i don't want this to be a debate
i think this is where we ask
questions and get answers well if you
let me finish
with this language in here mr tierney
and this is the same language that the
senate bill defeated
aren't you in fact making it impossible
for any clinic to adhere to these and
keep their funding
that would be incorrect um as you are
well aware
this language is currently in federal
regulations 42
cfr 19
and the current federal regulations has
caused some abortion clinics to choose
not to participate in the program but
other clinics have
continued to participate in the program
the people whose salaries are paid for
by taxpayer dollars um are not
pursuant to this amendment going to be
able to advocate
for abortion as a method of family
planning
and that's something that the state of
new hampshire has the right to do
it has the right to decide what speech
its taxpayer dollars are paying for
and if the amendment is adopted it's
making a choice
not to force the taxpayers uh to
subsidize
um speech advocating for increased
abortion access
so you're willing to forfeit low-income
women's health care services
for this amendment incorrect
low-income women's health care services
are going to continue to be provided
if abortion clinics decide that they
want to continue to have
the overhead subsidies as a family
planning project
they need to make sure that when their
rent their electricity
their other overhead expenses are being
paid for as part of the family planning
program that they have something that is
physically separate
from where they are performing the
abortions so that there's no
indirect subsidization of those
abortions
i think i heard her question to be
something slightly different i
i i think the essence of what she's
saying
or asking is um
do we believe that if this amendment
goes
forward that there would be a gap
in access to these services in any part
of the state
or are we confident that there are other
providers
that would be available to compete and
provide
full statewide coverage
thank you i'm very confident that there
are other providers to provide
all non-abortion services the
abortion clinics are all located in a
portion of the state
where there are other medical providers
manchester concord keene there are all
medical providers within
two miles of where there is an abortion
clinic and an abortion clinic can choose
to have
a separate both physically and
financially separate location to provide
their non-abortion services
and so it's not that the state would be
defunding them
if the abortion clinics decide to house
all their services um
together that is the choice that they
representative rogers do you have a
follow-up or another question ma'am
um i could but i don't want to
monopolize the conversation
are there any other questions from the
committee
i i just want to clarify something mr
tierney
uh you've used the term abortion clinic
uh
a few times in your answer and
the the term in the statute is
a reproductive health facility
are those two terms synonymous are they
exactly the same thing
so i apologize abortion clinic is not a
defined term
a reproductive health facility is a
and it's defined as a clinic
other than a hospital that provides
services and so a reproductive health
care facility as defined in rsa 132 37
1 does not include any hospitals that
may
you know also provide abortions in
addition to all other
services the hospital may provide
i'm not seeing hands raised by any of
the other committee members
um so uh mr ripple let's take a look
at the participants i see two hands
raised
okay for the members of who are
listening in uh i
i would like all of you that would like
to speak
to raise your hand because we have
uh a certain amount of time uh
representative leon
i think you have to leave now as a
matter of fact but
we need to finish by 10 30 because we
have other guests
i see four hands raised
i would like uh to keep remarks to
um three minutes uh
and i would ask you to
stick within the scope of section 34
as introduced or within the scope
of the amendment being proposed um
this this is not intended to be a
debating society
on on whether abortions are good or not
uh we know abortions uh are
constitutionally medic
constitutionally protected medical
procedure
and um and to the extent that it's a
constitutionally
protected medical procedure there's
really no
debate for us to have it's abortion is
an option that some people choose to
uh take advantage of so
representative horgan oregon i'm
i'm gonna ask mr ripple to uh to allow
you to speak
uh i would encourage you to remember
that as a representative
all of us are bound by the um protocols
of decorum
and that in that we just agree to
maintain decorum
you're welcome to speak sir er good can
you hear me
i can thank you good i'm not i'm doing
it on
a laptop on the bluetooth headset so um
i'll try to keep within decorum um
which uh you're a i know you're a
very fierce defender of and i was
not expecting to speak to this i just
want to say
this uh it is a constitutionally
protected procedure and
so some young women who use these
facilities state funding
will choose to avail themselves of it
not everybody in that situation
i'm speaking as an old man so this um
so this uh procedure is not something
that i'm
physically capable of having or but um
there are young women have the
same rights estate services as everyone
else and also this would i
believe effectively defund um
many very valuable uh health care
facilities especially uh
specially planned especially planned
parenthood and the other uh
inequality health center here in concord
so i think this is uh
so i think this is a bad amendment and
also it should not be handled as an
amendment it should uh
i believe it would have been more
appropriate to have this as a standalone
bill
so we could have a full debate in
committee which probably would have
led to the bill being retained and held
over the summer so just their stickiness
in the budget i think um
was not not the wisest thing to do so
uh i urge the uh committee
to uh go back to the previous section 34
and um and i think we'd be having a very
debate about this if uh
especially older men could get pregnant
and might need abortion
so that's um that's
that's about all i have to say so here's
the committee to omit this from the
budget
thanks thank you so much i i just want
to react to one comment you made about
the wisdom of this
uh i i don't want to impugn the judgment
of representative leon
who has introduced this proposed
amendment to
hb2 uh and i would point out
that we we are having a hearing and so
i'll take that as an apology to
representative leon
that you didn't know it's not wise
i mean i apologize but this is a bad
amendment and um so that's i'm not sure
how
much not sure how much more gently i
could phrase it and i i
that was perfect that was perfect thank
you
so uh we will go i think um
ms nelson is um up to speak next
and ms nelson if you could try to keep
your remarks within the contours
of the amendment and or section
um this isn't a debate about abortion
itself
so um please uh please go ahead and
introduce yourself for the record and
tell us what you think we need to know
please thank you very much and i
appreciate that this is not a debate
i am my name is deborah nelson and i
live in hanover new hampshire
and i would agree with the previous
speaker's remarks that this really
should be
handled and my
concern is twofold one is that
a gag rule violates medical ethics and
standards of
care and when i go to a doctor's office
it's
my hope that i will be given full
medical advice
without concern that there is something
being said that i shouldn't hear i
thought it was interesting that michael
tierney
continued to refer to these clinics as
abortion clinics and i appreciate the
fact that you corrected him
but he said at one point that the state
has
the right quote to decide what speech
the taxpayer is willing to pay for
and i think that a gag rule
is way beyond what the state has the
responsibility
for putting in place so i would urge the
committee to remove
this from the finance
and i would urge the committee to
take this out as i just said and leave
it for fuller discussion
elsewhere i have a lot more that i could
say about this
but i appreciate the importance of
limiting time
so again i think that this forces
providers
to violate their duty to provide
information that
is complete accurate
and honest to patients and it is a real
mistake
thank you thank you for your
testimony i
i won't i uh i won't answer anything you
said uh but i do uh appreciate you
coming in and talking with us
so i'm still gonna ask for a little help
mr ripple could you could you
uh move from um ms nelson
sure
good morning thank you mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is
christine stoddard
and i work for bi-state primary care
association
and bi-state represents new hampshire's
14 community health centers including
planned parenthood and the federally
qualified health centers that
participate
in the family planning program with dhhs
i agree with the previous speaker ms
nelson on the medical ethics
issue and i also want to draw your
attention to
federally qualified health centers are
funded in part by the federal government
and they're regulated by the health
services
and resources administration they have
a number of services that they are
required by law to provide
including primary care such as family
planning services
if they if one of their patients needs a
service that they cannot provide
they are required to contract for those
services with other providers in their
um area and they have to have these
contracts on file when they are audited
and when they are inspected by hersa
every three years
they receive financial audits every year
on line 13 i should say 12 and 13
this amendment would prohibit them from
entering into contracts with other
facilities including planned parenthood
and this is a real life example that one
of them gave me
if they do not typically stock larks
which
are long-acting reversible contraception
and it's because they can be expensive
to stock if they're not
used because they expire so oftentimes
they will contract with
a reproductive health facility for their
patients to access
larks if necessary this amendment would
prohibit them from
doing that and then put them in an awful
situation with herself and the federal
government
that's one issue that i would mention
this amendment would also
affect a significant number of
low-income
people from accessing health services
there's there's one there's one minute
left
okay thank you to give you an idea amisk
serves 15 000 patients cowas county
family health services serves 13
000 patients lamprey served sixteen
cowos is the only family planning
provider in
that area of the state where would their
patients go
if this amendment passed they would have
nowhere to go to access services
they provide culturally competent
services
including translation services where
would patients go
if they needed translation services
there is no replacement for these family
planning providers in the state of new
hampshire
thank you all right thank you and i
appreciate you
staying within the uh time limit there
appreciate that
sure i know it's a little artificially
constrained but
we just need to do it we know you're
busy thank you
so um i think representative leon has
gone if mr tierney is back
is still on could you
do and just limit your remarks only to
addressing the issue brought up relative
to
uh the medical ethics in a in a gag
order and then also if you'll remember
um
address the larks access issue if you
can
sure so as far as what has been called
um
a gag order this is current
um federal law its current federal law
um as to um how
federal tax dollars are spent uh
president biden has announced
um a plan to amend federal law
um and so this um you know amendment to
the new hampshire state budget of course
would only
apply to new hampshire tax dollars and
where new hampshire tax dollars are
going
an entity that wants to encourage
promote or advocate abortion does not
need to receive
new hampshire state tax dollars in order
to pay for the salaries of people who
are
encouraging promoting or advocating for
abortion it does not
limit the right of anybody who is
not receiving new hampshire state tax
dollars as part of a family planning
program
um from going forward and encouraging
promoting and advocating abortion it
just
limits the use of those tax dollars
for the promotion of abortion um are you
able to
address the access to the larks
sure do you know much about that so as
far as
12 and 13 okay that number one has a
perspective grammatical there's no
family planning grantee that shall enter
into
a new contract with a reproductive
health facility
those entities that have current
contracts for larks
would not be impacted uh by this
particular provision
that would just be um going forward for
those new contracts
i don't want to put words in your mouth
mr tierney but i but i think
what you just said is there that there
is a long-term issue potentially
about the uh ability of a family
planning clinic to access larps
if mr chairman may i respond please
no not until you're recognized okay
thank you so to clarify your
your statement um in future if
a family planning grantee needed to get
larks from somewhere
they would need to enter into a contract
to get them from somewhere other
than an abortion providing reproductive
health facility
but that would not be immediate on an
existing contract
only be for new contracts so there would
be time to
find out whether they get them from
dartmouth hitchcock
or some other provider
that is not a 132-37 provider
thank you for your answer and thank you
for keeping it relatively short
so uh miss stoddard was that you who
had another comment go ahead thank you
sir
um i am an attorney and our health
centers fqhcs i am not their attorney
however they consulted with their legal
counsel
and our national association of
community health centers that they all
belong to
and that bi-state belongs to and their
auditors
they cannot currently participate in the
title 10 program
because of this gag rule which is almost
identical to the one that you're looking
at now
that attorney tierney rep mentioned
if this were to go into place those
fqhcs would likely
be in the same situation and they could
not participate
in the family planning program i
understand that
the word shall enter is prospective but
their contracts
expire with all due respect they expire
and this will increase their ability i i
agree with that we we only have
about 15 more minutes and we have three
more people so i i think
i think you've added your point to the
record thank you so much
uh i see a rebecca mc
beath macbeth is that is that
representative mcbeath
can we just find out if you're
representative mcveigh
yes um chair edwards this is uh becky
macbeth representative from portsmouth
thank you you're you're recognized for
three minutes
and again the same rooms of the rules of
decorum
thank you i have two points i wanted to
mention
one going back earlier to the um the
professional advice the the dangers of
limiting that
as a practicing attorney in new
hampshire the only restriction i know on
my right
to advise my clients to a variety of
options
is criminal activity i cannot engage and
counsel them in criminal activity
and so since abortion is not criminal
activity i think that we're really
uh it's dangerous to take a medical
professional and eliminate any type of
options that they might feel is
appropriate to talk to their clients
about
and then number two um my um you know
the the sponsor
um our colleague from derry i think she
actually really
said what i want to say about this bill
and what i'd like you to remember
she said that these clinics are going
right up to the edge of the law
the law is that no funds no state or
federal
funds can be provided for abortion
services
and they're not this law takes it over
the edge
um and i i so i really asked you to
recall that
i know this is a controversial issue and
people are looking to try to push their
please don't imply motive or or
intention to
your opposition just represent your own
position please
i i apologize i didn't realize that i
was doing that i was
recognizing the controversials of the
issue and i was quoting um my colleague
who i respect
that she had said that um the current
uh funding sources what i mean the
certain clinics are using the funding
right up to the edge of the law
so thank you very much for the time to
speak
all right uh well thank you um that was
under two minutes and i appreciate you
uh testifying today
um i i think the next person to have
raised their hand
was miss kayla montgomery could you
come in and introduce yourself please
and and share with us what you know
or think sure um good morning mr
chairman members of the committee
my name is caleb montgomery i'm the
director of public affairs for planned
parenthood of northern new england and
planned parenthood
interaction fund and we strongly oppose
this amendment because it is a gag rule
on safety net providers
a gag rule prevents health care
organizations that receive
government funds from mentioning or
providing education
consultation or referrals for abortion
proposed amendment interferes with
patient-provided relationships
and would force providers to violate
their duty
to provide information that is complete
accurate and honest to patients
or being funded this amendment is
identical to the trump administration's
gag role and when that was implemented
in 2019 a majority of new hampshire
titles and providers pulled out of the
program
rather than comply with medically
unethical rules
therefore it is safe to assume that if
this amendment passes
the majority of title 10 providers
including those who don't perform
abortion
would again be forced to pull out of
state funding rather than lie to their
patients
while the federal gag rule is expected
to be reversed there are no timelines
available yet
so passage of this amendment means that
providers wouldn't be able to receive
state or
federal funds which of course is funding
that these organizations rely on to
provide
quality and affordable care to granite
staters
so to be perfectly clear this will
defund
health centers during a pandemic this
imposes totally
unnecessary physical separation
requirements which are
completely impossible to comply with and
these requirements serve
absolutely no logical purpose and are
only designed to force planned
parenthood and other health centers that
provide abortion
out of operation but if passed it will
have a dramatic
drastic and immediate effect across our
state for patients who are most
vulnerable
and i also want to say for the record
that government funds can never go to
abortion care
patients must use private insurance or
self-pay for abortion
all funds are completely segregated and
funds are never commingled
c4 advocacy is also not commingled for
example ppn
e has a sister organization called
planned parenthood new hampshire action
fund
which is a c4 organization
planned parenthood of northern new
england has 21 health centers in maine
vermont new hampshire and is a trusted
reliable source of compassionate and
affordable health care
30 seconds okay i will skip ahead um
i just also want to mention that someone
said that
uh folks could go to alternative medical
providers
that was mentioned by the sponsor all
know that those providers
don't care for people on a sliding scale
which is often no cost in 2020
planned parenthood northern new england
provided 2.4 million in free or
discounted care to our most vulnerable
citizens
and i also want to point out that the
sponsor mentioned
that this is an identical um
this is identical amendment to a an item
back in 2017 but what the sponsor didn't
mention is that
that amendment was soundly defeated um
because it is bad for public health
outcomes
so i okay i just urge you all to stand
with the
hundreds of medical organizations and
providers and public health officials
who oppose gag rules like these and
please just defeat this amendment and
if time i would love to talk about the
large issue thank you very much
i appreciate it so representative
wallner i i apologize i've been looking
at the attendees and you've
i don't know how long you've had your
hand up uh do you represent waller do
you have a question or
or a pertinent comment here that you you
want to make
well you know actually i think that um
ms montgomery is the right
is probably the person i should be
asking this question of
could you just tell me how this would
affect
um hospitals would this have an effect
on our
our hospitals it would have an effect on
hospitals who are in the title 10
program
um which i believe there are a few and
so yeah it would
would mean that they wouldn't be
eligible for state funding
so it's my understanding that this uh
legislation is strictly targeting
reproductive health clinics and in the
new hampshire rsas
that's defined pretty clearly as
uh as not being hospitals so it's
not being an attorney it's it's my
understanding
that it wouldn't affect hospitals at all
even those that do provide abortion
services
which are can oftentimes be essential to
saving the life of a mother so
so i i don't know that that can you
could you clarify
whether you really think it's hospitals
as well
because uh online let's see what is it
line uh 18 it talks about promotion
referral or support of abortion as a
method of family planning
so if someone if a title 10 provider who
happens to be a hospital
uh if a patient comes in and they do not
want to be they are pregnant and they do
not want to be pregnant
then that would say that the provide the
hospital
couldn't give medically accurate care to
that patient all right
thank you for the clarification i i
think i think that there's an
interpretation difference
is all uh but i do appreciate um
your opinion on it thank you thank you
uh
representative um waller did you have a
follow-up
no i just i was just curious as to how
this would um affect hospitals and i
think
um i heard from miss montgomery that it
would affect them thank you at
line four of the amendment and uh this
bill is pertaining to reproductive
health
care facilities as defined in rsa 132 to
colon 37 and i i think
that's the limitation of the scope of
the impact
of this amendment but i'm not a lawyer
okay to be clear so we're going to
move on if you have additional
commentary
please send us send us an email call us
but we we need to keep moving i i see
uh representative love i'm sorry i
didn't call on you sooner sir i didn't
see you would you
would you please begin your testimony
you have three minutes and i would
encourage you to maintain
decorum
thank you mr chair my name is
representative david love i represent uh
rockingham six uh which is derry um i
i do want to point out that uh in my uh
in my walking around town knocking on
doors and campaigning uh
the overwhelming feeling of the people
of derry is no money for
for reproductive health care facilities
uh they they do not want to have
any anything to do with funding abortion
this um
this amendment will will open up bidding
for for starters i haven't heard anybody
uh
mention that there'll be much more
bidding uh by
by healthcare facilities uh to to help
the the poor and indigent
of our our state it'll give the uh give
the state um
you know a better break that the
business would be better
uh more more providers uh you know
cheaper services for
the for the state and um you know the uh
as far as uh uh you know limiting
uh you know the the the reproductive
health care uh facilities now and uh you
know what they can do
um the i i always like to refer to the
billing as
a big problem uh you know when you when
you're allowed to co-mingle funds
uh you could uh a bill could possibly
read
and there'd be nothing stopping them
from doing this uh your initial phone
call
uh to to a reproductive health care
center uh 200
you know uh initial office visit 250
medication 300 and look at that the
abortion only costs 30 bucks
um you know in in reality the the the
state is paying for the abortion
it's there's nothing to prevent that uh
right now
uh you know that that's the way our laws
are if this amendment is adopted uh the
the poor and indigent people the people
that really need this this funding
uh will be served much better uh
there'll be no co-mingling of funds
there'll no be
there'll be no big executives uh
salaries uh uh being paid for by our
state
state funding uh there'll be no
lobbyists being paid for by one
thing and uh you know that
like i said i'm i mean wholehearted uh
support of this amendment
and uh and that's it jess
thank you representative love now you
were well within three minutes too i
appreciate that
minihan from the new hampshire hospital
association
would you introduce yourself and good
morning um representative edwards for
the record paula minihan state
government relations um
for the new hampshire hospital
association i
um just wanted to make sure that um
that you understand and i just wanted to
confirm
what um ms montgomery said that some of
the hospitals the way we
interpret this language and that this is
the first i'm actually seeing this
um but the way i um previously
understood the gag rule um that yes some
hospitals
with title 10 funding would in fact be
impacted by this i think this raises a
larger
issue um that was raised earlier that
this really
um is is kind of a complex issue and i
think it deserves um
separate discussion and a separate
hearing
i was not prepared to testify today at
all
um again this is the first i'm seeing
this but i just want i know the
um representative walner asked if
hospitals are impacted
i am not a lawyer but others that have
testified
are um and i do believe though from
talking with others in the past
that yes hospitals would be impacted
furthermore
i'm just concerned about the access to
care for
our most vulnerable especially during
the pandemic
and what this potentially could do
to impact that access which we are
very concerned about and would not want
to see
any access be limited for
important services to to our um
citizens in new hampshire so um and i i
am sure
um that the the clinics um that provide
family planning services because they
receive federal funding
are subject to audits um so i am sure
that they
have gone through those audits and i'm
sure ms montgomery and others could
address that but again due to limited
time um
i will stop my comments but happy i will
stay on if anyone has any questions
thank you representative
thank you very much um i i
i think to your point about not not
having had an opportunity to fully
prepare for today
i think you have a valid point
the hb2 process is
inherently less transparent than
our normal procedures for policy
committees
which is why i've made an effort to
get the amendment out there uh in the
most public way i could
and to you know alert particular
individuals
with interest that i need to have
interest in the subject to invite them
to come participate
um and so so and we're holding this
hearing
or meeting like a hearing in order to
um to at least leverage some of the
policy committee procedures
so if if um to your concern about not
having enough time to prepare one or two
things will happen we're either going to
vote this amendment down in which case
you your testimony uh was sufficient
or if we pass it uh you have another
bite at the apple
uh when the senate looks at their hb2 so
i think we're i think we're in midstream
of a conversation
at this point so um
mr i i see panelists
let's see what's going on over here uh
representative norgren
you have your hand up
probably this is out of turn but i think
the comments that have been made
um make it even more obvious that this
bill should have
its own hearing in the health human
services committee
so i hope that's something the committee
will consider
thanks thank you and um
mr tierney i see your hand is up and
i would ask you sir um to if you
in your coming remarks that you just
addressed very specific things that
you've heard
uh so that the committee has the
information it needs to make a decision
absolutely thank you um so as it
pertains to the
impact of this language on hospitals
what is currently the case right now in
the 2021
is that there is one hospital concord
hospital that is participating
in the um family planning program
and is complying um with the federal
title 10 language
which is where this language comes from
um so i just wanted to make clear in the
record
um that if a hospital decided to
operate a state-funded family planning
program
as it states in line 14 then it would
need to comply with lines 14
through 20 and that currently
uh concord hospital is complying uh with
this language which is
uh federal language so mr tierney i
think you just corrected
a bad observation i made earlier it
it because of line 14 down it could
possibly affect programs that are
hospital based and not just reproductive
health
clinic based or is that true a
state-funded family planning program
that is run by a hospital would be
affected by lines 14 through 20 if they
applied for and ran a family planning
program
well i was wrong so thank you for
clarifying that i appreciate it okay
uh i don't let's go back to the
attendees for a second
and i can do that i have a clicker
um i think
the people with their hands up have all
had an opportunity to speak
and so um at this point uh i'm
i think uh we can stop discussion on
section 34
and i believe uh we're scheduled for a
vote on
section 34 uh on monday
accurate
okay it's not it's not on my working
schedule but i'll add it to my working
schedule that
that will take a vote on section 34 um
on um on monday which i guess mr ripple
you you want to remind me that you have
to convert that into
an ols drafted amendment so that oh it
already is we haven't
yet yeah okay all right well so i'm
partially learning um all right
uh with that i i think we're through
talking about
um section 34. thank you
uh mr tierney for all your work uh thank
you
uh everyone who's come in and testified
um this is a this is a conversation that
we'll be continuing to have
so all right
has um is the dynamic duo
of mmis come in mr
rutters and mr goulet are they available
looks like commissioner goulet is in the
five or six people we have five or six
people from the previous conversation
that need to
be released okay and actually
uh because there are a number of people
in the attendees list if you could
actually raise your hand if you expect
to come in as a part of this
conversation that would make things
easier
you know who you should remove though
right mike tierney
representative oregon ms nelson ms
[Music]
minnihan
i think you got everyone kevin um
about okay attorney
so so let's let's do the simple one
first let's do
the section that's related to the two
hundred thousand
dollars for um
the adt hl7 transactions
i'm sorry i was i was trying to uh do
something else at the time could you
repeat that please
uh i'll i'll be more specific here in
okay and then if you can share section
outstanding
okay so um
i'll i'll let whoever wants to speak to
this go ahead and start the conversation
but i just want to
uh what we're looking for is
clarification
here and i'm probably the
person most confused about this because
um as i look at this it it seems to me
that we have information systems that
we've set up
to fire uh adt
hl7 event notification
out to specified other
enter through other interfaces to other
systems
so that they can use that adt event
notification
to plan coordinate
and coordinate uh ongoing patient care
and if if that is an accurate assumption
of what we're doing here
then i i don't understand what would
cost two hundred thousand dollars if the
initial setup
of the adt hl7 message has already been
invested in so so so that's the point
where i'm confused
i think dave and henry um can provide
more information
well i can start representing edward's
chair thank you chair this is david
weeders information services director
for health and human services
that was an accurate description of what
was implemented as part of the 1115
district waiver
with many of the providers across the
state
however it wasn't just the admission
discharge transfer component it was also
implementation of a shared care plan
network and it's
the ongoing cost to maintain that system
as well as expand
that that system into the seacoast
area that is not currently on online and
can continue to maintain
the implementation that just completed
recently at new hampshire hospital
so that 200 000 that's listed there is
actually
the general fund share of of the overall
cost to support this system on an annual
basis
going forward um the funding
for this solution expired in december of
the the providers actually were able to
sustain
the solution through june 30th of 2021
on their own funds and we're looking to
continue
that network of sharing to so that we
were able to
keep that keep the hospitals primary
care clinics behavioral health community
mental health centers
the post-acute facilities and payers um
in constant communication to realize
that
the benefits that we've had that we've
seen over the last couple years
so we've we've seen benefits of this
shared care planning and
emission discharge transfer program
reducing the number of emergency
department visits per month
as well as the average time patients
spend in the ed
has declined by over just under 10
percent
which essentially relates to how many
medicaid claims come in
as a result of those visits in the ed i
i i know that you guys have to leave
here shortly so i'm sorry to cut you off
but
i i think there's probably universal
uh agreement that that's a good policy
and that the shared
uh care plans are is is just good health
care policy
so i'm really just looking at the the
the money
and the way we're delivering the money
it sounds to me
like a few things are true but that that
i don't know who drafted this but it
sounds like
as drafted it doesn't really do
what you just described the need to be
it's it and and so i'm just wondering
if if we keep this as an hb2 item
if it's really as precise as it should
be
so that it it funds the program that i
i i think it does because it does say to
support expanded and continued
so i i think the language is broad
enough that it would support what they
okay so but this is money that's
intended to be sent
to health care providers to help them
pay for their
isn't it or did i mishear you
i apologize chair um actually it's for
us to
contract with collective medical
technologies to maintain that system
for the providers that leverage it today
so we would
we would continue to support that system
um
ongoing from for the next biennium
and from there so we would not be
providing the funds
to the providers we would be contracting
with collective medical technologies
which
is currently in place for this solution
to con to expand and continue that
emission discharge transfer
which also includes new hampshire
hospital
okay so so why at what point
would we not see this as an hb2 any
longer that it would just be
incorporated into the ongoing operation
operating budget of the state why is
this still an hb2 instead of just
absorbed
into a line within hb1
so i think the i think i had described
earlier that
this item was realized that we left it
out of the budget too late in the
process
and so hb1 had already been finalized
and so the governor's office put it in
hb2
so there's no reason that cat cannot be
so if we if we just put 200 000
in hb1 we could we don't need 38.
because you already have authority under
your ongoing operations to do this
correct and what to dave's point
something that i had
forgot about which is embarrassing but
uh
we would also need to add the federal
funds that would match to that two
all right so we have another revenue
stream to consider
yes if you would like i can
do a change request and provide it to
kevin for what that would look like and
i i don't i don't i'm tempted to say yes
but i want to hear
uh from the other committee members if
there's any question or conversation
i'm not i'm not seeing any hands up
um i i think i'd like to do something
with this
i whether we we we move it back into
hb1 as part of the ongoing operations
and you add back the
federal revenue number or i i just
i don't i i'm not a big fan of hp2 to
begin with
i know it's necessary but i'd rather
minimize its use
if we don't need it so if you
representative irf
please please tackle me if i'm going in
the wrong direction go ahead
no i just want to say that i agree if
karen's able to
provide the information for us to
incorporate it into hb1
both the general and federal funds that
seem to be the best
ripple would you get ready to show the
section of the governor's budget related
to mmis
please sure
so okay so ms rounds i guess i am asking
you
to to work with kevin um and whether
we we fix it because we're running out
of time
or uh the senate has an opportunity
to to to fix is the wrong word that
assumes it's broken
but to modify it um
you know just give give us some feedback
i i don't think it's the most important
thing we're working on right now
but it's i think it's in the worth doing
category
all right so
i think we're ready to talk about
the mmis portion of the budget again
and um just to just to frame this
uh mr goulet welcome sir i know you're
very busy as
as everyone is but um as we
went through um a funding exercise
the other day as a committee going from
the fy 21
base up to the amount of money that we
thought we may have available from a
ways a previous ways and means estimate
we started to run out of money as we
discussed
the mmis portion of our priorities
and and um and it's just a lot of
operating money
in fy 22 and 23
and we had some testimony from senator
clegg who gave us a 10-year history
um he he cited
some real systemic problems that that
the department has had
prior to your arrival prior to mr
wetter's arrival prior to the
commissioner's arrival
but but historically the department
has had problems
effectively and efficiently implementing
large its uh systems
and so so as we look at this it's a lot
of money
and and and we'd like to we'd like to
have confidence if it gets spent
that you have the right people and a
good plan
and and so i'll i'll stop there and just
let you all address that how you wish
well i'll start uh mr chair um
and members of the committee um for the
record my name's
dennis boule i'm the commissioner of the
department of information technology
um you know i haven't been party to the
previous testimony on mmis
but certainly we've had our challenges
as
as a state as all states do with mmis
because it's you know typically the
largest and most complex system
it has a lot of political sides to it
because of because of how
you know the the citizen impact uh
in in the total dollars that are that
are expended
through mmis and the fact that policies
tend to change
fairly rapidly particularly as as
party control ebbs and flows
that said the
dhejs team and my team
at this point i'm coming up on six years
as commissioner
we're at the best place we've been so
far since i've been here as it relates
to
effective management of our systems
overall but
really in particular mmis we have a
strong team on the business side hhs
with david weeders and henry lookman's
team
our doit team that's embedded in mmis is
the david and karen have put together a
budget
that fairly represents what is
required to run this extremely important
program
we i'm thinking that
and hoping that if you've had a chance
to look at the life cycle considerations
that
that david and myself have worked on
with respect to that
large and complex systems that we work
with the governor's office on as well
you'll see that we have a good long-term
plan that not only
will keep keep our medicaid program
running well
but we'll also do it at a more
predictable cost over time
i will that ends my formal comments i'm
happy to answer
i i appreciate that and and i've i you
know just to
let people know uh you've been willing
to talk to me for the
the past four years and and help me
understand what's going on with your
strategic planning process and
and i've seen the improvement and the
professionalism
of how the of your your organization
and the department's i.t group is has
been improving
over you know over the last four years
so
so i i i have confidence in you i i
i'm gonna let you uh ask a question here
in a second
uh representative erf if you still have
one but but
so so uh so so i'm gonna respond
just from a large i.t project planning
perspective
as i look at the authorizations and
vacancies
in the it staff of the department
i see 12 people on hand and 10 vacancies
out of the 22 authorizations
for um as
of march 11th and so
and i see an immediate opportunity to
begin spending 12.5 million dollars on
july 1.
and so i am just concerned about the
practical ability
to to hire the right people
with the right skills and experience get
them on boarded
properly and oriented particularly in a
pandemic world where nobody
can talk to each other face to face
then immediately pivot to implementing
an expensive large-scale project on
starting july 1. and so i'm just curious
what what you all have and again anyone
can respond to this but
but i'm just curious if you have a
project
plan that you've reviewed and that you
have the human capabilities
necessary to to pull this off on a
timeline where you need that much money
well thank you thank you uh mr chair um
i'm going to
give a a broad response and then i would
ask that david readers to comment as
well but
um you know the we're
we're looking at a couple things here
right we're looking at a continuing an
ongoing broad
program right and funding that as
it's contact as we're contractually
committed to
and then we're looking at the life cycle
considerations of the existing
contract and then we're also looking at
at the
reprocurement over time in terms of
recruiting i.t talent
um we we haven't had um
as much trouble as i have heard some of
my peers in other states
um recruiting in new hampshire i think
it's a couple things we're pretty close
to the boston job market and we have a
um
you know we have a better um quality of
life and if you're not commuting down 93
or group three
that means a lot um the other thing
that's happened too is i i've observed
that
um the fact that the culture and
performance of doit and our
relationships with the agencies
our improved relationships with the
agencies which you have observed and
commented on
um has hasn't gone unnoticed
for example if we bring a contractor in
for
a um making fairly high salary through
through contracting it's not unusual to
have them want to come to work for us
at the end of their contract in fact i
have a couple right now i'd love to hire
if i had the open position
the open positions that you referred to
i'm not certain what they are i might
want to qualify that but
i know that we did doit did unfund
a number of positions to make our
general fund targets
if the governor stays and and division
one has been considering
refunding some of those positions i
think that's what you're referring to
but i'm not certain
uh could could you qualify please that's
a that's
a fair question i i i don't i'm not
paying attention to division three at
this point i'm just
talking about division three the the
dhhs uh line for it
uh i has uh 22
authorized 12 hired 10
vacant i think as of the 11th of march
yeah i'll let the dhhs folks comment on
that
so um again chair those positions i
believe
are that you might be referring to are
the information services
positions in my group that are
supporting the pmo
as well as our security life cycle
management
and um and data warehousing for
the mmis specifically we have
several positions i believe it's six
that were vacant and
were unfunded um four of which were
unfunded in this biennium the current
biennium
that we were asking to fund
um fund a total of four positions in the
next biennium
and then associated with the alvarez and
marcel report we're also hiring it two
additional project managers to assist
with
the reprocurement efforts so what we'll
have is
uh well we'll be we currently have
posted an mmis director position
full-time position as well as a
part-time position to
facilitate the leadership alongside doit
myself and henry littman's team for that
strategic planning and direction
leveraging the doit embedded team for
that ongoing
life cycle management which they've been
doing a great job of the
initial step of the tech stack upgrade
and we would anticipate
uh nothing less with a second phase of
that tech stack the technical stack
upgrade
and then those those two additional
project managers that i
alluded to from the alvarez marcel
report recommendation
would be really focused on building
those
rfps working with across the teams to
do successful procurements and
implementations over the next biennium
so when it comes to that project plan
and resources
we we do recognize that we are at a
deficiency in terms of staffing to be
able to to do this but it's also in our
operating
budget to hire those those staff members
and have them on boarded again
recognizing um chair that the
complexity of onboarding people into it
and is
positions and specifically with medicaid
experience
we've we've actually found that it's
been successful
in bringing people with more generalized
backgrounds and training them bringing
them on board with our medicaid program
that that has been that has been a
successful method
of of learning it takes about four to
six months to do that
but we think it's actually right in line
with our plans for
for that reprocurement and the tech
okay so um
so i i think you are seeing
that you have about us i don't want to
put words in your mouth but what i'm
hearing is you you've got a six-month
lag to really hire the full team that
you need
to take on this project and so we're
talking about
maybe october-ish um
and and so i'll just come back to the
question of
is 12.5 million in general funds
in the current year starting july 1
really the right amount of money given
that it's hard to imagine
your team being really ready to
confidently
and effectively run this project
i'm just trying to make sure we don't
create a situation
where there's potential waste understood
um chair so when you're referring to the
12.5 million
um in in this on the screen shared
here can you ex can you qualify what
that 12.5 you're referring to so i can
address it properly yes yes sir that's a
that's a
fair question do you see the shared
screen
oh i see the general fund 12.5 million
is that what you're referring to
that's exactly it's 12.486552 thank you
so this operating budget specifically as
it breaks down
is associated with two two contracts
one's with conduit and one's with ntt
data
and so the general funds costs of that
line 102 for that 45 million
that the majority of which i think out
all of which is listed here
is associated with contracts with
conduit and ntt data so the conduit
contract is the lion's share of that
and that's the our system integrator our
provider services our claims management
system our third party liability
our electronic data interface actually
our data warehouse is in there
in a number of other modules to support
the medicaid program
and that's actually if you estimate the
number of people that are supporting
that system from conduit it's upwards of
130 people
that are working on that system to
support that
work the the increase that you see from
from a previous biennium to this
biennium as a result
of we were not funded for our operating
budget
in this current fiscal year i think
karen or athena might be on to be able
to tell that exact number
but we're bringing that up to date so we
are funded for the actual budget
plus we have had a we have
deferred maintenance on that system so
our oracle our
ibm licensing and pretty much all of our
infrastructure for software
is end of support and end of
end of life which
normally in some cases you could defer
that maintenance and continue
however it puts us at risk for um
decertification from cms which would
have a
6.6 million dollar penalty on our
general fund impacts
so what we were what you have in there
is actually the increased
work is to do that life cycle management
or that technical stack upgrade
which i would say 70 percent of the work
is conduit
and then the other 30 is that doit dhhs
combined team sort of strategically
and and through leadership directing
conduit to do the work
and then the remaining contract the mtt
data contract
is the quality assurance contract that
is required by
center for medicaid and medicare
services it did not increase
this year it was but it is required
for us to get our federal matching
dollars to do a third party quality
assurance review
so so just to make sure i'm tracking
this this is money you're paying a
vendor to maintain your legacy system
and your legacy system is old enough to
where
you have critical components of it that
are coming out coming towards their end
of life end of support
um so so and and and because of
if we don't maintain it we're gonna
potentially lose some cms
certification due to what due to a lack
of
adequate security due to why would they
remove our certification if the system
is still
operating so they require us to have
support contracts with all of our
vendors and maintaining patches of all
the systems
the ibm and oracle specifically um i
could go through the other ones but
those two companies
have indicated in writing to conduit
that they will not support the system
nor will they provide critical patches
for security or
or function unless we upgrade and so
and that that's where when they put that
in writing which is basically the last
last thing that the vendors do is when
they do that then they
then we're at risk where if conduit
can't support it
and it fails then the system would just
fail and we would have no
vendor vendor support um
just to follow up again i'm sorry i
don't know when do you guys have to
leave
i i i know we don't want to talk all day
about this but you all have a hard stop
where you have to leave i think
so so in the first year it's 12.5
million basically in the second year
it's 13.1
um it sounds like you're saying that uh
your vendor can provide you with an
upgrade
that will bring those component licenses
up to date and therefore remain
that is correct there are a couple other
components that were in our testimony
earlier um that this money also supports
which is
by a cms passed interoperability and
patient access final rule
that impacted both mmis as well as that
earlier conversation with the emission
discharge transfer system
where we needed to put in place changes
in the mmis for member access to data
so a component of this general fund
increase is the the annual
maintenance for that which is estimated
at 900 000 per year
to support that um those changes from
cms
as well as there's penalties in here for
us not
implemented the electronic visit
verification in
by january 1st 2021 and we didn't
implement that as a result of not having
the funds approved in the previous
biennium capital
request and and that's why you see the
increase in general fund um allocation
from
22 to 23. the penalties come from how
much did that cost
us how much do that penalty cost us do
you know before it is
miss rounds now the estimated um
i'll go ahead karen no go ahead dave the
estimated
um impacts for
this this this coming year is 864 000
and then the following year is 1.3
million dollars in penalties
of which the evv system to avoid those
penalties is
and those are general fund penalties the
general fund costs to implement an ebv
system is
is estimated at 564
yeah okay i
i i guess i have one more question
around the the
25 million over the biennium
do you it sounds to me like you've
talked to your vendors and these are
these are really firm
price estimates for the contract
modifications
or are they are they still estimates
these look pretty precise and it sounds
like you're saying
you've come to an agreement with your
vendors
they were precise estimates at the time
of submittal however
since the middle i continue to work on
negotiations to
reduce those costs we haven't finalized
the contracts
so the final contract should be coming
to the governor executive council for
approval within the next
month and a half at which time we will
have
um have those numbers
i won't ask you what you're expecting
for a reduction because
i don't want to lock you in and just
saying a number is going to do that
effectively
but can you can you tell me for sure
that it's you're in a not to exceed
position with these numbers
and that you may end up coming in less
and as a result
some of this may lapse back to the
treasury
i would i would defer to carrying on
that i'll comment because i
i don't get involved in the labs process
okay so representative irf do you have
any questions does anyone on the
uh representative irf you're recognized
just to clarify i think this is what you
were saying looking back at the
prior biennium's budget and it showed
three million dollars budgeted for both
20 and 21 which seems consistent what
you show for the
adjusted actual for 21 general fund
dollars i'm talking
i'm guessing you were aware of these
concerns
two years ago and and you made them
awareness i just can't recall
uh and and you just the plans weren't
allocated so you couldn't take advantage
of the
last two years to start this process
thank you representative erf and chair
for the question d
um over the last two bienniums
previously
specifically for biennium 2021 we did
submit a capital project for
mmis lifecycle management it might have
been named something different it was
not funded
so we need we deferred mate we continued
to defer maintenance
the previous biennium we had a capital
request
that was to do all of the work we were
funded at a fraction of that
and at an amount of i think 26 million
we
initially asked for upwards of 50
million
to do the work and so we have been
requesting over time to get the capital
funds to
maintain the system and in
in the case in the case of uh
the the capital budgets we were not
funded to do this so we continue to
bring them up
to the capital group for public public
works
review and then associate with capital
there's always operating costs after you
implement
so the the i and i think i saw something
in the chat so
maybe someone can reflect i believe the
three million that you're referring to
is the adopted budget versus what we
actually submitted
um we brought forward close to seven
million dollars to continue paying for
mmis as well as transferred
in another six and a half in general
funds
so so the cost was much higher than what
so some so mr glay you're just part of a
conversation here if you want to if you
want to
add comment go ahead sir well um
i appreciate the conversation about the
life cycle considerations and the
deferred maintenance
and and it was a bit of a theoretic in
my view it was a
good financial conversation i want to
bring in the
the aspect of um these this deferred
maintenance putting us in
a position where uh stuff isn't being
passed for security reasons
that represents a risk of citizen data
as well and i want to make sure that
that's in the public record that that
you know it's our all of our
responsibilities to do our best to
protect citizen data
and this is sensitive citizen data and
it's really important that we
that we fund this um this
refresh to i think do what is our basic
uh to perform our basic responsibility
in that
in that role so just to make sure i
understand
that risk you're laying out there for us
i i assume that one source of that
risk is if we have an oracle database
with sensitive data in it and it's
beyond
its service support and therefore it's
not getting patches it's not getting the
security patches that it needs
and therefore as we age past that
we become increasingly vulnerable as
hackers get to know of our
vulnerabilities that
is still up are there any other uh uh
questions here uh mr lipman you've uh
you've joined us i appreciate it and i'm
sorry for all the tech talk
but do you have something you'd like to
answer
i would i just say that the risk that
dennis uh spoke about
the risk to our provider network of not
being able to
perform in the risk of the state budget
i think there are a lot of risks here
that were maybe two years ago when the
budget was considering maybe
seemed a little bit theoretical now
they're real and um
we really need your support on this
request
you still have something thank you sir
do you still have something for us mr
gillette
you get your hands up i don't want to
ignore it yeah you were
you called on me right after i put my
hand up so i thought that was
you were just really quick on that but
no i'm good thank you sir
um all right i i do want to put one
thing on the record
um since the last time i think i did a
zoom with mr weeders
on on the call i i've had
two random resumes sent to me
by people interested in going to work
for
the department and i don't know who
these people are
and as a as a courtesy uh i forwarded
those resumes to
mr waiters without recommendation
just information and i'm referring
he's taught me how to refer people to
the online
job application service for for other
people to
apply um but i just wanted to make sure
you knew i wasn't pressuring you to hire
those people because i don't know them
i just in passing their resumes
do you have a you just put your hand up
or not
i was just gonna say chair thank you for
sending those they are
they did follow the formal process to
apply and we
we will be reaching out accordingly
based off of their
their qualifications and i appreciate um
i appreciate anyone that's able to send
people to
to that jar portal to make referrals for
them to work for
state of new hampshire so thank you for
doing that
totally your call what you what you do
what the information provided you
totally your call mr glay
your hand is still up so i'll just keep
coming back to you until you put it down
all right so um are there any
questions from the committee um
all right so i i think this was
important testimony like i i
i and we probably have heard all of this
once before but the importance of
hearing it
uh increased when we went through a
budget exercise
and we found this money right at the
cusp
of what we considered to be available
for investment
so um so it was i think it's important
that you came in and you
and you brought us back up to speed and
reminded us of stuff that we
maybe had forgotten so um
i wha what section have we been talking
about is this section 30
uh we did talk about 30 38
and then this has just been the mis
budget
i unless you guys have any uh
or gals if there's a gal out there uh if
you have any
questions or comments before we we move
on
do we have any questions from the
committee i for some reason i'm
my view is not as good as it normally is
i don't see any questions from the
committee and i'm not seeing any
more comments from our guests so
so so thank you very much i appreciate
you coming by
thank you gentlemen thank you very much
thank you so mr chair
uh i think the next section is the
section
uh with alvarez and marcel and there are
several people that
kevin needs to bring over so might i
request a
five-minute break while we do that and
have a chance to use the restroom
thank you for pointing that out i
appreciate that let's
let's do that it's uh it's 11 15
and we'll start back up at around 11 20.
great and if the a m attendees could
raise their hand that would make it a
little easier for kevin i sent him the
list of names but that will make it
easier
you have a document that kevin can share
that'd be great too
um i am i'm prepared to screen share if
that
makes it easier for kevin it does it
does thank you
uh just whatever you're sharing i would
probably need to put on the lba website
as well
i'm actually going to pull it right off
it's 11 20. i'm i'm ready when uh
our guests are ready
all right so i'm gonna
so i'm gonna start over here this is
um section 35 is the section
that we're talking about here this is
the 10 million
43 000 dollars meant to implement
the a m um
findings so going over
to the lba website here
this is where you'll find the reports
uh what i would mention here is there
are
the report and the presentation for one
a
and then one b uh the report and the
presentation for each of the phases are
very similar
so it's really about what your reading
preference is if you prefer to
read slides or narrative uh
but what you will find in the reports
are
is virtually identical it's more just a
um what kind of what level of detail you
like to read and how you like to
read it the other item which i'm going
to pull up on the screen here is item 11
which is uh tying back to that funding
that's listed in hb2 and
as long as the chair is good with it i
um
we'll turn things over to a m to do a
little bit of an introduction there was
a question yesterday
about could we understand you know what
a
m was here for and what they did and
then also
um we can go through each of these and
discuss
what each of them are if that works
you're doing great just uh just just you
know what you want us to know so
go for it okay great so i'm going to go
ahead and turn it over to brendan
staller to
cover sort of an overview and then
thank you karen good morning chairman
edwards and committee members
uh my name is brendan stallard i'm the
project manager for the alvarez and
marcel team
karen asked us to provide some
background
about our project and some context
around this report that we've issued
and which was released to you all this
week as we understand
so our team was brought in to conduct an
assessment
of the various programs that dhhs
administers
and oversees to identify potential
opportunities
for increasing efficiency and
effectiveness of all these available
services
with a particular focus on how covet 19
has impacted these areas of service and
for this assessment we relied on the
data from the department systems
policy and program documentation best
practices as well as the
experience of our subject matter experts
to identify to get a firm understanding
of how these programs are performing
where there and where there might be
opportunities to improve
and so we outlined requirements um to
implement recommendations
to address those opportunities
and where possible we've provided roi
estimates as well so we focused our
recommendations in a couple different
areas
long-term supports and services more
specifically developmental disabilities
as well as behavioral health and we
found that our recommendations
as they emerged fell into two broader
categories
um specifically shorter term
opportunities that can be implemented
within one to two years
this is this is really the case with the
the recommendations
related to behavioral health as well as
the opportunities related to
developmental disabilities which
while we see as pressing to address
would require longer term
implementation phases to accomplish
and so the result of this process
um coming out of this report is that the
department
has proposed these projects
in their budget package this this list
is really narrowed down to include
the projects which we feel the
department can
implement but would require support to
do so
but which will provide substantive
impacts to the service delivery
system as a whole
to follow my remarks here we have
included members of our team today who
are prepared to provide
a brief but more specific description of
each of these projects
in the proposed budget package as well
as to answer questions that you all may
have
let me let me make sure i understand
your your use of the term
budget package are these are these
uh i i'm seeing five line items here
are these five budget packages or or
is this one rolled into one and do we
already have the hb2 language inserted
as
we don't have the hb2 language inserted
yet do we
no this is all part of um
this item here so the
the 10 million 43 000
uh obviously is a little bit less than
the 10 million 260 000
so we would have to work within um what
the governor did appropriate in hb2
uh but all of them are funded as all of
these are technically funded as part of
that hb2 appropriation
and so what i'll do is i can cover the
first one here
uh the 4e funding because before you get
going this is a good place to let
so are these also already incorporated
they are the cop these no they are not
double budgeted
i don't see any other questions great
so what i'm going to do is just cover
the first one and then
i will turn it over back over to
different members of the a
m team to cover each of the others to
talk about
um why this project's important and uh
the return on investment so the first
one
and the reason i'm talking about this
first one is because as division three
members remember from
last biennium this is one that's near
and dear to my heart
we knew that there was a problem with
our 4e funding we knew that our claiming
rates were lower
than states around us but we were really
struggling to identify
what our issues were and so a m was able
to do some analysis and help us
develop some processes that are going to
improve that
so we do need to make some small changes
to our computer systems
uh to be able to implement those changes
there is an anticipated
roi of anywhere from two to four million
dollars a year in general funds which is
fairly significant uh the governor's
office and i talked
uh quite extensively about how to
include it in the budget
uh my recommendation was to increase the
department's laps
because we're not sure exactly what the
timeline might be
for making that and as representative
earth is familiar with it will affect
probably about
i would say at least 50 different class
lines because it'll be
the salaries and wages of employees who
earn 4e
as well as direct contracts with 4e uh
so
that um is our recommendation that you
increase the lapse anywhere from
two to four million dollars uh to
represent this i don't believe that the
governor's office did end up increasing
the lapse
any questions on that one any questions
representative for example
uh thank you mr jim so just to clarify
that last
comment the the
who to four million dollars per year is
the savings
yes the cost is between
is about half million dollars is that
what i would read the uh
it's actually about fifty thousand
dollars okay
so you're suggesting decrease in the
lapse that's sort of
recorded in the budget by the fifty
thousand dollars
uh no i would suggest appropriating the
fifty thousand dollars and
increasing the labs by two to four
million dollars
i would say less than the first year
more in the second year
okay increase the lapse so that's to
sort of
count for the savings you're
anticipating is that the idea
correct okay correct the department will
likely lapse more general funds
because we've budgeted more general
funds than hopefully we will need when
we start earning this
extra federal revenue okay thank you
very much
so ms rounds i'm looking at the column
headings and i'm just having a hard time
tracking the projected annual savings
is that in a column no savings are not
represented on this
spreadsheet but they would be within
these individual reports
on each of the findings the potential
savings are listed
okay so so just just sort of
let you know how busy people think
that have to make decisions it's nice to
see
the investments offset by the
savings and the return so that we can
see what the
what the cost benefit analysis is on
kind of all on one sheet
so sure i can update this spreadsheet if
you would like
no i no i think that's fine i'm just
talking about for future
purposes it would have been it would be
nice for for me
to see a cost-benefit analysis per
project
all on one sheet but this is i can work
with this go ahead
understood thank you so if there are no
other questions on that one i
would turn it over to i believe matt
everyone this is actually tyler stone
sorry
uh hi uh thank you karen thank you mr
chairman and members of the committee
can everybody hear me okay
great excellent i'll be addressing
the line items here that relate to
critical time intervention or cti
as well as cmhc funding there are
three primary benefits to implementing
cti
the first is its positive impact on
the health outcomes of new hampshire
citizens cti increases the likelihood
that people transitioning
out of psychiatric hospitals will
reintegrate successfully back
into their communities thereby avoiding
a relapse that may put them
back into the hospital extensive
academic research
supports this randomized controlled
trials the most rigorous form
of research have found that cti can
reduce hospital readmissions
by as much as 26 the program
helps people leaving hospitals identify
and secure
the critical things they need to live
independently
a job housing food supply
relationships with family and peers as
well as the mental
and physical health care they may need
every person's cti helps
reintegrate into their community and not
be readmitted to a hospital
is someone once again able to be a
contributing member
of society the second benefit
is cost savings to the state the average
cost of an admission to new hampshire
hospital
for someone under 65 is approximately
per person per day many individuals can
stay at the hospital for weeks
or even months and as a result the cost
can quickly add up
cti in contrast is far less expensive
averaging around four thousand dollars
per person
per year thus while there is a recurring
annual cost to pay for cti providers
that is to say the programs and the
workers around the state that would
actually deliver cti services
there is also recurring annual cost
avoidance
we anticipate that every million dollars
spent by the state on cti
could save 1.3 million in avoidable
inpatient hospital costs
i i need to i need to ask you to be
patient with me for a second i i got a a
couple of questions to help reorient me
to what you're
you're speaking on of course the first
is the macro view uh or is does this
sequence on this matrix imply
uh recommendation priorities like you
would definitely do number one
then you would definitely do number two
and if there's one that's on the cusp it
could possibly be dd redesigned
is that is this meant to imply priority
it is not
it is not i would say that these are all
[Music]
i i just missed it i must have drifted
off for a second there
what is at its essence not not the
paragraph or two but just at its essence
what is a critical time intervention who
is doing what with the patient
to make it a critical time intervention
it's an excellent question mr chairman
critical time intervention is a program
that lasts nine months and it is a
individual or sometimes a team of
individuals that assist
people transitioning out of psychiatric
hospitals so when they're discharged
after having had an acute mental health
episode
it helps them leave the hospital and
reintegrate into their community
so that they have all the essential
things of life to be independent
back in that community on a sustainable
footing meaning
finding a job housing access to food
and ensuring they have access to the
mental health care or physical health
care
they may need to stay in the community
the whole goal
is to prevent readmission to a hospital
which is oftentimes a less than ideal
mental health outcome and is also
oftentimes very expensive to the state
intense care coordination lasting nine
months after discharge
to make sure that all the social
determinants of health
are satisfied for that patient
i i think that is a fair
characterization uh especially the
emphasis on the social determinants of
health
at the end yeah and so so
for example if there's housing and
security or food insecurity
uh is does that care coordination
include
finding vouchers or other programs to
support that individual that is
certainly possible yes sir
possible but not present at the current
time
no what i mean by that mr chairman is it
will vary based on
on the individual if they need
assistance finding vouchers
for example then the cti worker could
help them find those vouchers
all right i'm sorry i interrupted you
absolutely and and police interruptions
are welcome
the third and final benefit of cti uh is
that it will help reduce the number of
individuals
on hospital wait lists by creating a
more efficient model of care at
hospitals the need for such weightless
reductions
i think we all know is is considerable
it's greater now in fact
than it has been really since dhhs began
tracking data in 2015.
um fewer individuals admitted to
hospitals
or readmitted i should say and instead
reintegrated into their community
means less pressure on the hospital
system allowing hospitals to admit and
process individuals
faster and more effectively
so so i fully accept
um i guess i
i guess where i'm going is on the
savings i want to know more about the
savings and that's not what you're
talking about right now
but i i understand the theory of how
there's going to be
cost savings that that's that's going to
accrue to the state
and i accept that this is good clinical
care in theory i got i'm not
debating the program i'm just doing the
finances
and and on the savings to what extent
do you have proof or evidence
or that the savings will materialize
as opposed to a kind of a managerial
cost
estimate of theory
our report mr chairman goes into this in
in much greater detail i would obviously
encourage you i'm just sticking my
finger into this one to get some sense
of
how how how deep this is of course
um i i do think the report will answer
that question in great detail
i would say just in the moment here
briefly
there's a lot of academic research that
supports the idea
that cti can reduce readmissions to
hospitals including some of the most
rigorous type of research
rcts or randomized control trials our
analysis was predicated on
using that evidence which is extensive
to model what the reductions would look
like
at new hampshire hospital and what the
attendant reduction and cost would be
assuming a reduction in readmissions
outstanding answer representative walner
did you have a question
it looked like you were reaching for
no okay uh you can continue
uh mr stone thank you sir
the last item i would comment on uh in
the document here is on cmhc funding
the primary benefit of adjusting how
cmhcs or
community mental health centers of which
there are 10 around new hampshire
the primary benefit of adjusting how
they're funded is
cost savings to the state cm agencies
play a vital role
in the state's continuum of care they
offer a range of mental health services
to the citizens of new hampshire
one such service is assertive community
treatment
or act which provides treatment for
individuals with serious mental illness
in their community rather than in a
hospital setting
the state currently funds this
particular service in the form of annual
contracts
for each of the 10 cmhcs
moving much of this cost to medicaid as
we propose in a report
in the form of a bundled rate for these
act services
could save the state up to 1.7 million
dollars per year
the department has the resources to
develop this bundled rate
and submit the appropriate documentation
to the to cms the centers for medicaid
and medicare services
for approval the associated one-time
cost here
is the anticipated cost of a third-party
accounting firm
to review the rate before its submission
which is a a very standard practice
when setting rates of this kind
representative has her hand up will you
take a question
certainly so i guess a question i have
on all on all of the items here um
i think it's they're really interesting
items and i guess my question is
how much discussion has there been with
the providers of these services i'm i'm
asking it here
but i've also i'm also particularly
interested
in the dd system how much
participation have they had in taking a
on the subject of provider engagement
for cti and cmhc i would have to defer
to the department
representative and i would have to defer
thank you can we get that input at some
point uh chairman
oh sure i'm just um i was just about to
ask mrs rounds if
she thinks there's somebody in the
participant list that might be able to
address that
i was looking to see if katya was
there she is i don't um
katya if you're available can you raise
your hand sometimes sometimes staff are
listening but doing other things so they
they may not be available i don't
believe it
i believe they listen to every word i do
did you um hear the question of there
you are i did i did sorry i just had to
go
shut the door in um henry lippmann's
face because
um i wanted to get the noise reduced if
i have
that was my mad rush to the door um
so the question could you repeat
um representative um walner
i just want to know i'm just wondering
on all of these items
um there's a obviously on all of these
items there
there are providers who provide the
services
how much engagement have you had with
the providers have they
had input um do you plan i mean
what what are the plans for getting
input from providers around this
that's that's a great question so um
in particular cti is a program that is
known to new hampshire
through our integrated delivery networks
through the medicaid transformation
waivers so that has been something that
has been
worked on by the community in your
communities
and we so that informed
as part and you can see in the report
who was consulted but that helped inform
the um proposal we
anticipate so we also have
spent a lot of time talking about how do
we sustain
the funding and the
programs that are associated with act
and with other community mental health
center programming
and not rely so heavily on general funds
and we've had those discussions um
off and on throughout the years
make no mistake that this includes a
stakeholder
process that is going to be robust and
so we're just getting our
internal teams together but we
anticipate a formal engagement plan
and for example we had a meeting with
the community mental health centers on
wednesday
so i briefed them on the report made
sure that they had it and had seen it
and fielded questions we did the same
thing with the integrated delivery
network
uh leads team leads this morning
um so we're going to continue to have
the informal
you know make sure you saw the report
and you read through
and then we're going to be formalizing a
stakeholder process
working with a m and members of the team
does that that also includes the dd
community as well right
i would be speaking out of turn if i
were to speak on behalf
of that particular line of work but i
believe that that's front and center
in the report as i read it um that there
there has to be
i mean that we can't do these major
significant changes without stakeholder
input
great thank you thank you when we get to
the
dd item i'll um have kevin bring deb
sheets over as well yeah great
see that she just raised her hand so i
have a question for you
miss fox and i appreciate you coming in
and answering questions
i um okay so i just think i sometimes
think in risk management terms
and and and the way i'm looking at this
is a potential
risk that i i'd like you to comment on
and maybe mr stone
is is um you're asking
for these for basically program launch
authorization you want to go do these
five programs and you want the money now
to do it
but i'm but i'm hearing in response to
representative walner's
question that
we haven't completed sort of the
stakeholder
buy-in phase of the project and so i'm
just
concerned or i'm curious rather
whether we might be launching
projects that may not be
exactly what the stakeholders are
looking for
could you could you speak to that risk
and i'm sure
it's it's nothing but i'd like to hear
it
so i will only speak for the behavioral
health projects
and reiterate that cti is something that
has been tested through the
demonstration project through the idn's
and that um we want to scale it up
um and so there already has been buy-in
at the community level
and we want to scale it up and have it
statewide so
we have ambassadors for that who are
already in the community and our
stakeholders
that's not to say that there won't be
complications as we work through the
details
but we're planning to work those through
on the funding source funding is always
an issue and
always at risk and subject to
available general funds so anytime
we can double our money so to speak by
um including medicaid including services
and as a medicaid billable service
um has been beneficial to the system
so i'm not sure if karen wants to give a
broader perspective
um from the department but my question
was really about the the risk we're
going to accept if we begin
implementation of these programs prior
to
you know fuller stakeholder uh buy-in
and i think you addressed that
so thank you uh representative erf do
you do you have a question sir
just a quick question from mr stone he
he said the cmhc
was moving from something to medicaid i
can't recall what the front something
was
so in the recommendation maybe tyler
would speak to this directly
but in the recommendation is to bundle
services
for example assertive community
treatment is
a program that is highly intense
but it requires um a lot of work by the
teams that are
at each of the community mental health
centers that
are funds that are not reimbursable by
medicaid right now so they're activities
that aren't reimbursable
so there's um so the idea is if you
bundle a rate you can
include those types of services
um through medicaid as opposed to having
to tap the general funds
um for unreimbursable services
what does it mean to bundle services so
they become medicaid
uh available so to speak
so i'm going to look to a m to give a
more um instead of the hack
job that i would do um to give a a
better response
i i'd be i'd be happy to answer um
in in in plain english uh act for
example as a service
there are actually many discrete
services that it comprises and those are
billed separately
developing a bundled rate would mean
there is one rate one payment for all of
those services instead of many discrete
services being paid for independently
and to
quickly just double back to your your
previous question sir
um the the idea is to move cost
from what is currently being borne by
the state to having it run through
medicaid so that there are savings to
the general fund in new hampshire
i i totally understand the the idea and
the concept i got that completely
i'm just trying to understand you know
you're suggesting that by grouping these
costs they become
medicaid allowable whereas independently
they are not
all right you can resume if you can
uh that is uh the extent of my of my
commentary uh
thank you very much mr chairman and
members of the committee i'll i'll turn
it back over to
karen thank you for all your hard work
on this you've probably been working on
this for quite some time
so the next one that we have is the smi
imd waiver and to answer representative
walner's question
uh the the primary stakeholder
in this waiver as of right now anyway is
new hampshire hospital
and joe christie who is the cfo over at
new hampshire hospital was
was involved in this finding and looking
at the data and the analysis as well
so i'm going to go ahead and turn it
over to a m to talk about the imdb
waiver
thank you karen and thank you chair
members of the committee for the record
my name is jane again with uh
alvarez and marcel so as division 3 has
heard over the past couple weeks the
emergency department waiting list
is experiencing a resurgence after
having been virtually eliminated in
march of 2020
and the chair noted in the hearing on
new hampshire hospital that at its core
this is a problem of inputs and outputs
programs like the philbrook adult
transitional housing center are part of
the solution
an additional inpatient or imd capacity
is also part of the solution the key
here is to increase
throughput across the system and get
people in crisis the care they need
when and where they need it so what i'd
like to talk about this morning is a
potential catalyst to increase
throughput
which is to say expanding the state's
imd waiver
from the current focus on substance use
disorder to include
serious mental illness as well now why
is a waiver required that may be a
question running through your mind
since the beginning of the medicaid
program the federal government has
prohibited medicaid reimbursement for
inpatient behavioral
care or care received in institutions
for mental disease imds
over time cms has loosened this
restriction in the face of growing needs
and pressure from interest groups most
notably and recently
by granting waivers of what is sometimes
called the imd exclusion rule
31 states have received waivers for
substance use disorder
sud including the state of new hampshire
and most importantly for our discussion
today
seven states have received waivers for
serious mental illness
and one state's application for that
waiver is still pending
another logical question might be how
have we gotten by without such a waiver
so far
while new hampshire hospital benefits in
a major way from the disproportionate
share hospital program
which offsets the cost of care that
would otherwise be uncompensated
mr christie shared more information
about this during the new hampshire here
at new hampshire hospital hearing
earlier this month
now the only imd in new hampshire that
benefits from this arrangement is new
hampshire hospital
something which has limited the ability
and interest from private sector
partners
in working with new hampshire to reduce
the emergency department waiting list
now what we're what we're trying to do
with this imd waiver is to encourage a
partner to develop a private imd that
would expand
inpatient services and perhaps even more
importantly
to offer needed community-based services
such as mobile crisis teams
or transitional housing just like the
philbrook center again it's about inputs
and outputs basically with medicaid
being such an important payer for
behavioral health services
no private sector organization would
want to risk the losses
that would be incurred if medicaid
cannot reimburse stays for people age
22 to 64 which is currently the case
under the exclusion
one final crucial point to make what
would be the cost of doing nothing
reducing the waiting list is not just
benevolent policy
as important as it is to connect people
in crisis with the care they need in a
timely manner
there are hard dollars that cost the
state to maintain people
in emergency departments while they're
on the waiting list
from the hearing on march 1st we heard
that there were 1424 boarding days
in the month of january 2021 on a run
rate that equates to over 17
000 boarding days per year now the per
diem cost
of boarding someone in the emergency
department is estimated at two thousand
two hundred and sixty four dollars
per day per diem now that's cited from
an emergency medicine
academic journal that we reference on
page 13 of our report
large portions of that fall on the
general fund
whether it's through medicaid
reimbursement or through
uncompensated care in the dish program
we estimate
that about half of the amount 50 is
ultimately attributable to reimbursement
so if someone has insurance other than
medicaid
then the state is off the hook for that
portion
but if the person is on medicaid or if
they're self-pay
which largely ends up as uncompensated
care that does fall to the state's
responsibility
the other half almost always falls on
uncompensated care
which does cost the state through the
dish program
so we walked through this in detail
beginning on page 19 of the report i
don't want to
take up time here reciting figures the
key takeaways i think
are that it's actually much more
complicated than those calculations
anyway
there's the direct cost of boarding in
terms of reimbursement
on medicaid or uncompensated care which
we just highlighted
but just as important are the risks to
health and safety for other patients and
emergency department staff
as the chairs noted previously folks in
mental health crisis
aren't best served in emergency
departments that's not what the purpose
of emergency departments
is and last but not least this is also
hardest to quantify
is the exacerbation of symptoms while
people are being boarded
which could lead to longer lengths of
stay in the imd more intensive courses
of treatment
etc i'm open to any questions the chair
has them or from
other members of the committee are there
questions from the committee
i i have one if there aren't any from
okay actually i have two so so as i've
heard this problem over and over about
emergency room
boarding and the throughput issue i keep
imagining a graphic that looks like a
pipeline
that describes volume going through as
throughput
and then what the catch points are and
how many are popping out
and being stuck without able ability to
transition to the next
phase with the associated costs
of those individuals that are trapped
uh outside the throughput do you have
any cool graphic like that in your
report
so we do have a graphic of kind of the
pipeline we could attach
the cost to that but it does show and i
can actually
pull it up on the screen that's all
right
you're just giving me more reason to go
look at the report i just we haven't yet
because we've been really busy so
so i appreciate you coming in and giving
us uh uh
you know a spoon feeding on this or at
least me um
uh what was my other oh okay
so uh in parallel to this discussion
there's a discussion around whether or
not the state
should be building a a new 60-bed
forensic mental health hospital and so
there's been some questioning about
and there's been some statements on both
sides of this
of whether or not that having those 60
beds if they were
assuming they were staffed um that
that would be a nice chunk
of the solution to our er
boarding problem did did you all
take a look at that component
and whether or not do you have anything
categorical to say about whether or not
a 60-bed forensic hospital
mental health hospital would would or
would not
so i think it would definitely help
because there is a kind of one-to-one
correlation right every
uh person who is a forensic patient
which
you know are completely on the state's
uh
finances right there's no medicaid
reimbursement or anything available for
that
every person who is a forensic patient
at new hampshire hospital who could be
moved
uh to a new forensic facility uh would
free up a bed
right which would which would be filled
pretty quickly unfortunately with a
waiting list such as it is
um i don't have the current numbers of
how many forensic patients are admitted
at new hampshire hospital i'd have to
follow up with uh with joe on that
okay i don't want to put words in your
mouth but i think part of your answer
was
was no you didn't specifically look at a
60-bed
hospital being part of a bigger solution
that that's correct it wasn't it wasn't
part of our report
no problem no problem i just i just
wanted to know because we have like i
said a parallel conversation where
we have that issue kicking around as
well uh so thank you that was a great
briefing uh miss
representative erf do you have a
question and then representative wallner
had her hand up
jesus thank you mr jimmy just a quick
one i missed when you talk about the
savings on the
yes so we we estimated those at
approximately
half a reduction of half in the waiting
list
there's a range of uh in the report 3.3
to 4.4 million dollars per year
thank you and what what would happen
with that one
is the implementation is closer to
sometime
in fiscal year 23
so new hampshire hospitals budget would
change
entirely right because they would no
longer receive dish
or they would receive medicaid and so we
would have to come to fiscal committee
with basically a redone budget for new
representative norgren has her hand
did you did you understand what ms
i just had a question um
so one of the things that the report
says
is that they would have to re-engage
outside
group to provide those services
right now as we know new hampshire
hospital
is currently staffed by some dartmouth
hitchcock
doctors so i was just wondering what the
ramifications
i don't i don't think it would have any
ramifications as far as the services
that we need at the hospital from
contractors
i don't think that would change okay
there was some reference in the report
so okay i think and jay i'll let
you jump in here but i think that that's
more referencing that there may be other
providers that might come to the state
and
and uh open additional beds with this
waiver in place
yes that that's exactly the uh the
essence
uh aaron it's that um it's to attract
private sector operators to open a
facility i
i don't think we uh we didn't express an
opinion or recommendation as to which
private sector providers those might be
there cert there could be some
uh within new hampshire but there are
certainly some from outside of the state
who have expressed
uh interest to the commissioner in the
past in doing so
president of northern your hand is still
up do you have a follow-up
yes so so we
so are we talking about an out of state
somebody else running this facility
other than
the state so not new hampshire hospital
new hampshire hospital
there's no plans to have that run by it
by anyone else
this would be a provider coming in and
opening their own beds that they
operated
now whether it's an out-of-state
provider an in-state provider
i mean it could be any of those but
think of it similar to like drf beds
you know a provider opens those beds in
the community
and runs and operates them in the
community
very well thank you okay
i want to do a time check it's a couple
minutes after
uh i had been thinking that we would
take a 12 15
uh break for lunch until one o'clock
uh so we got a couple of scarcities to
manage here one is we still have uh
another line item at least
from a m and we have ms rounds you're
you you go away this afternoon at some
point at two o'clock i think
i do i actually was able to extend that
to 2 30. so
because i i want to i don't know if you
had a chance to reflect on the
footnote question and then the other
questions that we asked
uh for you to come in today it seemed
like you had
the stage on about five items today
yes i i think that we'll be able to to
representative wallner your hand is up i
just wanted to know
if you are planning to go past
3 15 because if so
um i need to uh kathy
sharon and i need to make another
arrangement
so okay i'm sorry i'm this is one of
those
technical answers that people made sorry
my no it's all right i'm uh because
you're the one that has to listen to my
answer but
so uh i am not planning to go past 315
but i am planning to
hit a pretty heavy agenda that i sent
out before
uh we started this morning and
i can imagine that that agenda
demanding more time than we have between
1 and 3 15.
and because today is such a critical day
for us to try to get
information so we know we're asking
of mr ripple um i i
i really have a strong desire to push
okay so i guess my question is if we
have a 315 commitment
should we be now letting them know that
we won't be there or
how how how long is your commitment it
would probably
it would probably be for one hour
um before you go i think you guys should
go
be able to do your commitment
particularly if you don't have travel
uh you're doing the zoom thing i assume
um yes yes it's soon
um i i think we could agree
to have you suggest what we could
continue to talk about in your absence
and it's all going to be recorded and
if if you want to leave one person
behind to sort of
you know participate live with us maybe
that's an approach
but i i i'll try to try to give you some
opportunity to do your 315 obligation
could i ask that there be no votes
during that during that oh absolutely
that's that
yeah i wouldn't even consider that okay
thank you
i think that clears that up for me thank
you
so all right so we just used uh
four minutes of your time available so
we can end it around 12 15. mr
nagy can you do that we will certainly
try so i'm going to go ahead and turn it
right over
to drew smith
great thank you karen and i i'd like to
thank the chairman and the other members
of the committee for the opportunity to
discuss our review of the developmental
disabilities
delivery system operated by the bureau
of developmental services
for the record my name is drew smith
with alvarez and marcel
in our discussion today about the
funding requests for the developmental
disabilities redesign
i would like to frame this discussion
around two buckets bucket one comprises
of a waiver redesign
rate development and a modernization of
i.t infrastructure
bucket two includes our recommendation
related to intensive treatment services
in relation to the first bucket of items
our team conducted an in-depth review of
the dd service system in new hampshire
we concluded that under current
processes there are inadequate controls
in place to manage waiver spend
and to control cost this lack of
operational control has led to an
inequitable system of haves and
have-nots in new hampshire
these inequities are driven by three
primary factors an unfettered waiver
structure
antiquated rates and the in inadequate
access to data
specifically under current waiver
operations all participants have access
to all services once they enter the
system with few controls
to help guide individuals to the most
appropriate services based on need
under the current reimbursement rates
which have not gone through a
substantive redevelopment process
since calendar year 2007 there is little
historical understanding of the cost
basis or assumptions used in the current
rates
leading to further misalignment between
service costs and service reimbursement
and lastly as provided in testimony by
dltss earlier this week
bds operates using outdated siloed data
systems preventing its ability to more
robustly manage the system
and authorize and monitor services as
outlined in our report we strongly
recommend that interventions be
undertaken
to correct these challenges core to
service management such investment will
realign
service spend with individual needs much
more appropriately
the goal of these recommendations is to
move away from a system of haves and
have-nots
to one where each participant gets what
they need no more no less
this occurs through better utilization
management rates that more appropriately
cover service costs
and helping align the array of services
someone accesses at the initial point of
enrollment
these are key to long-term system
sustainability and are an important step
to promoting outcomes for those with
developmental disabilities in new
hampshire
the total investment to the state as
outlined in the report for these three
recommendations is between 800 000 to
1.2 million dollars however
by not making these investments the
issues outlined earlier will continue to
compound and drive the likelihood of
over serving some
or more importantly underserving others
raising risks to health and safety
shifting to bucket 2 i would like to
take a moment to briefly touch on the
larger financial industry services in
our report
intensive treatment services as noted in
at the time of writing 38 individuals
were being served in out-of-state
long-term residential services at an
average cost of three hundred and eighty
four thousand dollars per person
peaking at just under five hundred
thousand dollars per person in some
cases
more directly this group accounts for
less than one percent of the waiver
population but five percent of total
spend
beyond cost importantly is the impact on
people being moved
out of their local new hampshire
communities and away from family and
natural supports
driving this need for out of state
placements is an is inadequacy and
current reimbursement rates
as well as lacking community
infrastructure to support the complexity
of needs
of these individuals our report calls
for our partnership between the state
and private providers to build out the
physical infrastructure
needs for these supports and a rate
schedule that can more appropriately
support these individuals in new
hampshire
while we do project potential long-term
cost savings in this approach
it will require investment by the state
to incentivize this shift
depending on the level of state
investment we project the state could
break even within five years more
importantly however
is bringing people back home reuniting
these families
and providing opportunities for
individuals to re-engage in their new
hampshire communities
i hope this information helps in your
review and i thank you for your time and
i'm happy to answer questions
i have a question um i'm looking at the
estimated one-time costs the range
between 5.9 and 6.9
and then i'm looking over at the
personnel costs
oh okay that answer never mind uh but
but so i'm looking at 5.9 to 6.9
how much of that's a lot of money so
what are we investing in
sure it's a really good question you're
correct it is a lot of money um
you know what i'll say in our review of
the service system is there there's been
a lack of investment to be
to be blunt in the dd infrastructure
over over a longer period of time
the majority of this investment is
really around the
the development of the in in-state
intensive treatment services
there's an infrastructure need that that
the state needs to partner with provider
private providers to really build out uh
that includes specialized group homes
specialized capacity within those homes
so i'm i'm so sorry i
i i we only have just a few more minutes
and
i hate but um okay so when i hear
infrastructure i think things i don't
i don't think people and services i
think
buildings networks like physical
networks pulling electricity you know
hard infrastructure are you using
the word the same way as i am or are you
talking about
service capability by having more
providers coordinating and talking with
one another
sure no this is talking about physical
infrastructure for the need for
intensive
supports for these individuals typically
dually diagnosed
there's not a capacity right now in the
current group home structure within the
state of new hampshire to support these
individuals
within the state and so this is a
infrastructure development of a grant
program
to work with providers to build physical
infrastructure
to be able to bring people home to have
a safe place for them to reside within
the state of new hampshire
so is this really truly a one-time cost
or
are we going to constantly need to be
building out
that's a good question right i mean the
intent here is to
have these be a grant program that the
state invests in to help providers build
the initial set
uh i wish i could tell you there are
going to be people with
complex needs coming back into your
system there will probably be a need to
continuously develop this program
i can't say there have been new people
that have been served in holiday
placement since the writing of our
report
so there is a need there and so there
will be more investment i think this
initial call
is to really incentivize initial
development of this service in the state
to get out of the uh the practice of
sending people to other states for the
service
and building the provider capacity
representative
you have a question i i do
so my understanding of this i
um don't have a deep understanding of it
for sure
but my understanding is that presently i
miss the number of people you said but
presently we're sending people
um to providers that provide
intensive services and i think a lot of
them are in
um are a lot of the folks are in
uh florida is that my understanding am i
correct correct
and how many how many people are we
sending
so there when we wrote this report there
were 38 individuals served in
out-of-state placements primarily in
florida but also in pennsylvania and
massachusetts
okay so we are
so i assume those those um
providers that are providing the service
to our to our residents
just send us a bill for them um or do we
negotiate
uh you know it's a little bit of both
right i mean there is a negotiated
contract karen i don't know if you want
to talk more
more directly around the contracting
agreements with the state and the
private providers but
there is negotiation that happens with
out-of-state providers just like every
other state negotiates with with similar
services
yes yes deb is also on the line i think
some of the the struggle is the capacity
and the
the number of of types of providers
across the country that are available to
do this so by building our own capacity
we build
competition that that um that lowers
that cost
um i think deb is also on the line to
talk hopefully maybe just for a minute i
know we're
at the lunch time but about provider
engagement
well we're bringing her in let's at
least hear representative erf's question
in case she's got a twofer opportunity
great thank you just very quickly i
didn't catch the savings
for the two buckets you talked that mr
sure so so again we project that within
five years
the break even on the initial grant
investment of the uh its program
would be achieved and then part of that
is really dependent on the
individualized rates of participants
once during the state
so we do project ongoing savings we
projected that between point seven
or seven hundred thousand to two point
three million dollars
annually again there's a lot of
individualized person
centered pieces to that uh similar with
bucket one around the waiver redesign
and rates there's a lot of policy
decisions that will drive
to the impacts of those numbers that we
did not want to
project policy in this approach and so
yeah we did not put
forward a projected savings in that
bucket
representative uh it's deb sheets the
director of long term supports and
services and i just wanted to
provide um some additional contacts for
the question by representative wallner
uh as you know the
state contracts with the 10 area
agencies and the area agencies
are the entities that provide that do
the contracting
with the out-of-state providers as
needed for intensive treatment services
i think it's important to understand
that when we started working directly
with a
m the first thing we did is look back
before we looked forward
and in 2019 sb 86 directed the
department to take a look
through a commission study with our
partners in the legislature
at how we provide supports and services
for individuals with dual diagnosis
and that report clearly indicated that
we had
not the best continuum of care and that
we needed to take a look at addressing
this moving forward that was one of the
first study reports that i handed over
to a
m and that helped provide context for
the dialogue
that had pretty significant stakeholder
engagement on the part of the area
agencies the legislature as well as
families
and experts then in 2020 hb4
directed the department to work with the
governor's commission on disabilities to
take a look at our system overall and
opportunities for improvement
and there was a report that was issued
relative to that that
took a look at the possibility of
creating in in-state supports for
intensive treatment services
it took a look at what we were
considering relative to case management
to autism spectrum disorder
and it also suggested that we take a
look at our current waiver structure
so once again that stakeholder input
impacted the way that we began our
dialogue with a
m uh in the past two weeks the
commissioner and i have met
with the executive directors of the area
agencies
we've explained some context for the a m
report
we have made a commitment to the area
agencies that once they've had a chance
to dig deeper into the reports that
we will circle back and meet with them
again but most
importantly the recommendation from a m
takes into full consideration that this
is a significant system change
and the ability to listen to all
partners relative to this system change
is step
one and priority one and so the
stakeholder engagement process
is the first thing out of the gate that
we will be considering
i think it is very important that it's
understood that this
engagement includes the potential to
build
ten four person group homes in
cooperation with our system here in new
hampshire
so that we keep our new hampshire
citizens in new hampshire
and get them the support that they need
at a reasonable cost
and that they are connected to their
families and that
we are supporting them a hundred percent
which is what we need to do as a system
here in new
will you take a question through the
sheets absolutely
okay so um like three years ago
i i was taking a look on a committee
to dealing with group home parity
and there were different state
reimbursement rates for different group
homes
and as i went on site visits
i heard that a huge component of
the revenue for every group home are
charitable donations
and so i'm just curious if we're
selecting
four locations for group homes
to what extent those group homes will
will have a
sort of a naturally growing
donation base that's necessary to
supplement them
have you thought about that angle so
we're always thinking
about private public partnership when it
comes to supporting our system
one of the benefits of having an area
agency system that does heavy lifting
is that they do a considerable amount of
fundraising to fill gaps
and that is something that we will
okay i i i i guess i've just always
sensed these group homes to have grown
organically in a community and then
that that's developed the the
sort of the ecosystem of donations for
each group
group home and i i just am curious if
we're doing a top-down
group home location process if
if we're going to have that organic
donation site to supplement it but
again as as drew pointed out these are
quote unquote grant programs where we
will be leveraging local resources to do
the builds
because in reality it is the local
resources that have the connections with
the communities to determine where to
put a group home
how to work with the local um
police fire department etc to build a
positive approach there so we will be
working locally
okay it's just if our experience with
other group homes
uh carries forward the state's not able
to
fully support them and i i hate to
be building infrastructure that may not
get supported fully
um but all right so that's that's just a
concern
um are there other questions from the
committee
i'm not seeing any uh mr smith i i i
apologize for cutting you off
i'll give you the final word anything
you want to tell us well
what we're glad to hear
no i i thank everybody for the
opportunity today i i do
hope that you have an opportunity to
read the full report there there's a lot
here our team looked across the entire
dhhs system and so there's a lot to
digest but it was a great opportunity
and we thank you for your time
let me let me ask you a parting shot uh
it feels to me like these are five
independent projects that aren't
necessarily
integrated and so in theory
one could pick and choose among these
five
to to create a unique bouquet of
solutions
or or must we take all five if we're
you know i mean there's probably a quote
here around the only thing that you must
do in this world is
pay taxes and die but i i mean i think
this is this isn't meant to always be a
menu right
uh you know the hhs program and i'll
just speak from our experience in new
hampshire as well as other states
these populations are unique and the
projects that have been outlined here
are unique to those populations
um you know i don't think we want to put
the state in the decision point of
picking one group over the other
we pulled these programs out because we
think that these recommendations are
timely we think that they will have a
substantive change
on the way that individuals are served
within the state of new hampshire
i don't view this as a menu i view this
as an opportunity for the state to
really build these programs back up
and really make this commitment to the
supports that are offered individuals
look like you may want to have a comment
there are these
are these integrated or there's are they
separable
is she frozen are you asking me so cti
and i would say cti cmhc and the imd
waiver
are all very integrated they're all the
mental health system
so they're they're all very integrated
but to drew's point
you're essentially talking about three
different populations here
i i i heard mr smith's point i i get it
but i do want to be able to understand
it from a different angle so what three
did you say were definitely integrated
all right and don't don't take my
question or comment to mean anything
other than i'm just
trying to understand all right uh
at this point it's 12 24. uh i think
we can uh break for uh lunch
and because we still have a really busy
agenda i'd like to start
at one and and uh my proposal is ms
rounds
we'll we'll give you the first bite at
the apple you know you got
like five things we want to talk about
and so
i'll just let you start talking and
knocking them out
i just would ask that if you if we've
got something we can look at
at the screen that we we have a visual
to go with what you're talking about
is possible i will do my best to do that
and i
i do appreciate that thank you all right
no we just appreciate
uh your your being here and your
responsiveness and
and uh and everything you're doing to
help us so so thank you
and i see that this wondrous seller has
been
on the panel pretty much a lot of the
time
so wanda is the lead with brendan on
this project
uh wanda also ran the developmental
disability system
in the state of south dakota for many
many years so she's an expert
in that area as well oh well i'm from
nebraska go big red
so all right um but i don't think she
has anything to say
or does she thank you miss thank you mr
chairman members of the committee
um i am the the executive from
alvarez and marcel that's overseeing
this project and i
appreciate the time um that you provided
um our team to present on these really
important issues
thank you my pleasure and i think i do
appreciate the spoon feeding it's
it's great to have experts who will just
answer questions the way you have so
so we'll see you all at one o'clock if
you could stop recording
mr ripple and put us on recess with the